the stuff we teach folks is that it's so
aggravating because it's so easy to
understand what to do and it's so hard
to do it because in every case we're
having to look in the mirror and say you
you're the problem you've been screwing
up
you've been disorganized you've been
overspending you're the problem when you
look in the mirror and you start saying
that you are changing your life you're
changing your life because you're taking
control of the variable you can control
and by the way it's the number one
variable outside forces are not your
problem very few cases do I run into
that outside forces are the problem it's
almost always be me and I like stuff and
I live in a culture that likes stuff
other than a culture that's forgotten
how to cook everybody eats out every
stinking meal and we can't figure out
why we're broken obese
you know we're just crazy we're just
nuts we've lost our minds and so we just
have to stop you have to just change it
let me tell you if you do the same stuff
with money all your broke friends are
doing with money you're going to be one
of your broke friends all your whole
life and you're never going to elect a
president that's going to fix your life
and you're never going to elect a
congressman or governor that's going to
fix your life Jess is on to something
man she's figured it out she's the
secret sauce in her life you're the
secret sauce in your life you're the one
that makes it move you're the one that
sets your destiny you live in a free
country really we have this wonderful
thing called liberty and it is a
blessing to those who take control of
their own destiny and it is a curse to
those who refuse to take control of
their own destiny because they sit
around and watch other people win and
whine about the fact that other people
are winning it's not fair
have you noticed that other people have
more than I have it's just not fair I
can't stand it other people win bigger
than I win I can't stand it it's just
not fair it's not fair and I'm gonna
have a whole webpage on wealth
inequality and it's not fair and I'm
going to whine shut up it's not fair you
people that don't work or aren't good at
what they do get paid the same as those
that work and aren't good and are good
at what they do that would be unfair if
you work 80 hours a week it would be
unfair for you to be paid the same as
someone who worked 40 hours a week it
would not be fair so equal never is fair
because talent is not equal effort is
not equal and work ethic is not equal so
you're never going to have equal results
that's the downside of Liberty the
upside of Liberty is you're in charge
baby you're in charge you're the man
you're the one who gets to fix this
you're the woman you just decide I'm not
living like this anymore I've had it I'm
not gonna live like this anymore I'm
done I'm sick of making this kind of
money and being this think it broke I'm
tired of it you're not going to fix this
with interest rates you can't borrow
your way out of debt you can't
consolidate enough times for your debt
to go away there are no interest rates
where they pay you you're always paying
them something and you have to look in
the budget and go I can't afford to go
out to eat all the freaking time I'm
broke we can't afford to go on vacation
and put it on a credit card again we're
broke
I can't afford to buy out of the car
that I don't have the money to write a
check and pay cash for it again we're
broke
and so it you're the best thing happened
to broke people is they start realizing
they're broke people and you change the
habits that made you into broke people
because if you keep doing what you've
been doing you're gonna keep getting
what you've been getting the
insanity the 12-steppers say is to
continue to the same thing over and over
again and expect a different result we
have to change our habits our actions
our process and in order to do that it
becomes a character change yes your
character changes you freaking grow up
adults devise a plan and follow it
children do what feels good don't do
what everybody else does figure out what
broke be but broke people are making fun
of your financial plan you're right on
track and everyone have you got broke
people in your family that make fun of
you when you're winning everyone have
you got some friend that rolls their
eyes when you have when you're
successful at something you need be
careful who you're hanging out with
because those people are called losers
when you tear down other people's
success by definition you're a loser and
so don't hang out with them and
certainly don't take their input on how
you're going to live your life no I love
you I'm going to love you from a further
distance because you're acting like a
loser and you're going to say positive
awesome things about my positive awesome
plan because I'm about changing my life
into a positive
awesome situation and I live in a free
country and have the right to do that
ready set go hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show so you have to break
the cycle you have to flip this thing on
its head and make it behave you've got
to get so fired up and wired up that
you're broke friends think you've lost
your mind
you